check it out i got this story here from
timcast.com inflation soars to nearly 40
year high um i just wanna i want you
guys to understand the consumer price
index rose six point eight percent in
november that means
from november of last year till this
november if you did not get at least a
seven percent raise a six point percent
raise then you are losing money so i
would like to stress people will forget
your words people will forget your
accomplishments but people will never
forget you voted for joe biden because
this is part of the reason why we have
this don't shout out to the best
political shirts.com but i genuinely
mean it i mean a lot of people who voted
for joe biden this is what you get
now i think we all know that inflation
has been really really bad we don't need
like the latest metric to make us
understand this what i really want to
get at as we're ragging on the snobby
elites is this article which oh my god
this one
a flame in me from the intercept
inflation is good for you
over milk prices inflation is bad for
the one percent but helps out almost
everyone else
that is
this is a funded
shill controlled opposition garbage
media outlet lying to people
let me just explain to all of you
inflation does nothing to the one
percent in fact
it helps them
one thing he points out in this article
that is true is that debt becomes worth
less as the dollar becomes worth less if
i owe someone 10 but then 10 can't buy
you anything anymore i basically don't
owe somebody any money right and he
argues that's good for poor people
because poor people hold all the debt
the problem is they still have the debt
now they can't afford to buy food either
so maybe they'll get lucky and
eventually their wages will go up and
then they can pay off their debt but let
me make one thing clear if you got 50
000 in debt and that debt gets devalued
because of inflation and you make 15
bucks an hour your 15 bucks an hour is
devalued because of inflation too and
you still can't pay after that and now
you can't buy food but a rich person can
take their money as soon as they get it
invested in stocks and assets which will
go up in value during inflation and
they'll say has no effect on me and i
tell you this rich people that go to the
store they don't know or care about the
price of milk the intercept and these
far left establishment crackpots are
manipulating poor people so they can
keep their crackpot biden in power and
this one pisses me off yeah because it
actually hurts people
tremendously it hurts the weakest it
hurts the poorest people in our society
and it takes advantage of them in such
an unfair freaking way where the federal
reserve is literally printing money
giving it to their friends in wall
street and everyone else is finding it
harder and harder to make ends meet and
why is that well well it's not because
of a political party it's because of the
financial system being literally a ponzi
scheme that everyone's going through and
this is not just the internship this has
been a coordinated effort through a lot
of corporate media organizations that
have been repeating the same lines
inflation's great cnn had a similar
headline cnn just had don lemon on
singing the praises of the president of
the united states saying can you believe
it so ah
five cents less for gas absolutely
insane rhetoric look at this celebration
victory in poor people becoming poorer
and the rich people becoming more
powerful than they ever have been
through the largest transfer of wealth
in recorded human history that we're
going through right now and it's
sickening to see happen right in front
of our eyes and then the corporate media
lie to the people saying it's not even
happening you're you're you're better
off no you're not this is no dirty dirty
game this makes me
this is this is this is this makes me
angrier than i've been for a lot of
issues you know uh granted i'm not
nearly as mad as when the fbi raided
james o'keefe that was clearly
infuriating for me but to see all of
these massive multinational billion
dollar corporations trying to convince
poor people that they are gutting your
savings your life your ability to buy
food everything you work for for your
family for your kids trying to build a
better life they're stripping that away
they are gutting you you are being
screwed over by the elites and then what
do they do they have the intercept
progressives and cnn tell you it's a
good thing it's happening these poor
people who get stuck in this and believe
this trash that's what i want i don't
want any power over any of you i don't
want any money from you i want you to
know that you have agency that you
should keep the money you earn that you
have a right to control your labor and
that these big companies these media
companies are lying to you so that the
amazons the walmarts these billion
dollars these billionaires are stripping
away your value all their cronies and
the federal reserve and the government
are printing away money and screwing
every one of us and you know who says
this steve bannon says this they call
him far right we have more in common
with left populists than we do with the
establishment the problem is people
watch too much cnn and believe this crap
if you are look if you are on on the
left if you're progressive or you know
someone who is please explain to them
that cnn is a trash rag that is lying
about everything
we're being we're being ripped off by
the entirety of the establishment well
and then what they do too is then the
federal government wants to give
everybody a lot of money right they want
to not only not only they're jacking up
their prices and everything they want to
divide americans from their basic
ability to earn a living on their own so
they want to feed everybody money
they want to feed everybody all of these
services so that then americans are just
entirely reliant on the federal
government
and don't have the ability to
uh you know earn their own bread take
care of their own families you guys no
and then we're going to be then we're
afraid to speak up why would we how
could we possibly speak up against
something that's so big and has so much
control over our lives at that point
they control you know they control
healthcare they control our income they
control our families and that's what all
of these programs are about that's what
these vast social engineering programs
are about where it's like let's give
everybody some free money it's not free
money it's control money it's money to
to take your liberty away from you you
guys sound like crazy conspiracy
theorists i believe uh jim cramer of
cnbc who just said that
today we have the strongest economy
perhaps
that i've ever seen so yes that's
literally what he said today i don't
know if you guys saw but the democrats
were tweeting about all of the jobs that
joe biden has created and i really hope
that all the rest of you guys saw this
chart that they put out showing the gas
prices are coming down well if you look
closely it's zoomed in so tight to the
cents on the dollar it goes from like
338 to 336 and they're like oh my gosh
the gas prices are coming down and it's
like you guys are joking right yes
seriously joe biden is not creating jobs
he's allowing people to go back to work
because i i'd like right i'd like you
all to see it as a general yes a
generous god yeah
take a look at this
this
the democrats on twitter welcome to the
biden boom got ratio and it says jobs
created in the first 10 months of
presidency uh under uh under the uh
underbide and the economy has
outperformed the past four republican
president's job growth numbers the funny
thing about this is
they they're
it's just if you fall for this stuff
first
it would be important to compare biden
to obama oh that would make obama look
bad yeah and they know that and uh and
clinton no it's just the republicans
they don't mention that the job growth
under biden is actually stagnant and
what happened was there was a major
collapse when democrat governors locked
down their states and then it bounced
back only a certain amount and it
struggled to recover since then but of
course if you take away six million jobs
and then snap your fingers and say you
can work again and you get 5.8 million
jobs then all of a sudden they're like
look how many jobs you made
these people are evil man i don't like
mitch mcconnell i don't like lindsey
graham i don't like kevin mccarthy i
don't like the established republicans
their whole plan is obstruction and do
nothing and you elect these people again
and they will do nothing we need to
primary them i don't i and look this is
why i cheered when aoc be beat crowley
in new york because screw the
establishment democrats i'll take
wherever i can get the problem i think
aoc is still just another establishment
democrat but she's wearing a bernie mask
that being said primary all of them i
donated to a progressive leftist who was
trying to primary nancy pelosi because i
would rather someone be in office saying
i have bad policy ideas but i recognize
these huge lists of problems and be like
i can agree with that and we can work we
can work on something but when you have
the biden administration the
establishment democrats the hillary
clintons i came we saw he died and their
whole plan as well if we blow more kids
in a foreign country maybe that'll be
good for the economy then we'll claim to
have some kind of win and they gaffe
with afghanistan we have a real
opportunity to end that war they just
burn it to the ground they destroy that
i would rather have some some crackpot
lefty who's like i just want americans
to have healthcare and then i can be
like that's a bad plan for healthcare
but at least we agree we're not going to
spend our money on blowing up kids well
and it's so interesting too that now
they're laying the groundwork for having
like a whole ukraine thing it's like
they can't exist without having some war
to go fight but they're not going to go
against china china's their business
partner no and we saw that already you
know we should have been standing up for
hong kong and we obviously we should
have been standing up for hong kong we
just let them get totally destroyed that
was a that was a relatively free place
you know and we just let them we just
let those protesters be imprisoned
uh we let the the pro-democracy movement
die
we and we did that because we're just
shilling for china it's so stupid like
these activists were out there with
their lives fighting for democracy in
hong kong fighting for free speech you
know
working on that so hard and we just let
them down and in letting down hong kong
i do feel like we let down this
democracy project and now you hear the
administration sake you know coming out
there talking about the importance of
democracy globally and it's just such an
obvious
garbage thing they don't believe it at
all they just don't even believe it if
they believed it we would have stood up
for hong kong yeah i remember being in
hong kong during the uprisings and the
protests there and they were absolutely
intense and there was a warning
i remember spray painted saying
you know this happened here but it's
going to happen everywhere soon and it's
only a matter of time but they said it
more eloquently i forgot the exact
phrasing of it but uh to your point tim
i definitely agree with you mandatory
term limits put new people in there let
them give a give a try
kick them out kick all the people out to
prevent all the corruption i don't know
a lot of crap i think term limits could
possibly result in shadow organizers
and so there's challenges there's
already a lot of shadows it's true it's
true but why should we tell ron paul he
can't run anymore because we're upset
that nancy pelosi is running too you
know what i mean it's like one in a
million yeah you know i suppose it goes
either way right you term limits get rid
of the bad but they could also get rid
of the good the way i see it is that
they're all uh criminals some criminals
are better because they have more
experience so
let in the new criminals whenever you
have someone stealing money and then and
then using it for their own purposes i
have my own definitions of my own
understanding of it but
you either have expert criminals or you
have rookie criminals i rather deal with
rookie criminals that don't know what
they're doing that aren't intertwined
with the system as much as the people
who are definitely intertwined like
nancy pelosi i think it's crazy that uh
we're supposed to say dr jill biden but
we're not supposed to say dr rand paul
right right right right she's totally a
fake doctor she's a fake doctor thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you